and they give it new terms you know you
believe in energy
and are you spiritual and he called it
that he said this is the evil eye
this is uh we also have a
evil eye the stories of the jal and the
tricks that he does
on people it it it comes to the same
thing
crystals oh you shouldn't touch other
people's curses oh really
energy i put it under my pillow when i
go to sleep
sleep with this and like put it under
your pillow they assume
that there's a connection between the
rubbing of the buddha's belly
and the good things happening you know
is this acceptable
well you know people say the same thing
about drugs
but you'll hear you'll see people saying
mata me like when they swear on
something
necklace and when she put it on
it stopped the tushing stopped in her
eye
knocking of the wood when some people
talk those who do black magic
okay a form of [ __ ] if you talk to the
people they don't believe their god
they have the divine divinity but
welcome to the dean's show most of you
know our next guest dr
shaibala phillips he's here with us to
talk
about a very important topic dr sheikh
bilal phillips how are you
i'm fine alhamdulillah how have you been
my pleasure to be here again
it's good to have you it's good to have
you back here on the dean show
pleasure so we wanted to uh talk about
some of the modern day things that are
out there
that some of the even it's going
mainstream you know people get away from
talking about religion
and they give it new terms you know you
believe in energy and are you spiritual
that i do yeah yeah i definitely believe
in energy uh spiritual is the right word
i'm a big believer in like the universe
yeah you know
manifestation uh destiny all that
uh spiritual enlightenment uh we some of
these uh videos that we'd like to uh
go ahead and kind of comment on have you
reflect over because this is kind of
what the youth this is kind of what like
the new generation
and it's kind of just a new packaging
it's kind of the same things that
happened before but kind of uh
just a new packaging so we want to get
your thoughts on that uh the first one
is this video here like a cross yeah
almost like a pyramid
in the middle we have oh you shouldn't
touch other people's christmas oh
really yeah i'm sorry you're good i
apologize now you're good
like my ocd was just adjusting it a tiny
bit you're good do you have to wash it
later yeah i have to sage it
so the thing about crystals they have a
lot of energy and they absorb energy too
so like when when other people touch
them
yeah your energy goes on too okay but
you're i'm not tripping you're gonna
go again now you hear some of these
terms you hear somebody's terms like
crystals
energy i put it under my pillow when i
go to sleep
sleep with this and like put it under a
pillow because it almost like helps you
come into like a spiritual awakening
okay so that's really cool it just gives
off really good energy this apparently
has um
interaction with like your third eye i
don't know if you know about that some
spiritual stuff
it makes me feel good what's your
reaction when you see things like that
this is nothing new it's been around for
a long time
you know people were wearing rings even
now
you know rings with certain uh
stones in them and claiming that these
stones
were good for this and good for that or
the other
um what we are calling new age religion
now from way back in the 70s uh late 60s
with the hippie movement
you know this was the outreach into
uh experimenting with everything that is
out there
you know and um
this is just you know a revival
in those individuals or it may not even
be really a revival in the sense that
what was started in the late 60s went
through the 70s
just continued but you know it there's
there's a rise and a fall
you know uh popularity and you know
people get tired of it and move on to
other things and
a new generation comes in and gets
involved in it
and um if you even go all the way back
to the time of the prophet
may god's peace and blessings be upon
him and and the
and all the prophets of allah
you know people were into wearing
um metal things bracelets around their
arms
you know and believing that these would
prevent
evil and you know bring good
and so all of this is there's nothing
new you know
um so so i don't
see that it is anything
to get really alarmed about
um we we have in the dean
clear instructions you know with regards
to these matters
when we take when we put it in front of
the law you know it it falls apart
because it's all a part of the la
ilaha yeah there is no other god no
other power
no other deity entity
you know uh which controls
what happens in this universe except
allah
used to repeat regularly that there is
no
power or movement except by the will of
allah now before we started people i
read your introduction
who you are what you've been doing and
for all these years educating people
on the purpose of life you came from a
background of being a christian and then
actually you were in communism and then
at one point uh atheists is that correct
so you kind of were all all around the
all around the world and then you came
to islam
and then you know for the people out
there these youtube stars are people who
reach millions and millions they're some
of the most popular out there and then
if you're not well grounded in your deen
people watch this even muslims sometimes
and they think oh this is cool you know
what i mean
you know and so they start experimenting
and falling into many of these traps of
shaytan
so even if we can reach our message can
reach people like this because
from the video you hear okay i was in a
very dark place in my life
when you hear that what does that signal
to you i was in a dark place in my life
and all of a sudden now
they start experimenting and now he's at
their road of experimenting you see okay
he's got one point he's got the cross
then he's got the crystals then when the
muslim this is a muslim actually who's
interviewing him
his name is fouseytube he touched it by
accident and the guy said oh
do i have that's my something about a
sage and you gotta know do you have to
wash it later yeah i have to sage it
so well the dark place in life
you know is something that everybody
goes through
their their ups and their downs you know
um the level of up
depends on your knowledge of allah
as well as the level of down
when think into uh misguidance
and you know as they say the drowning
man will clutch at a straw they will
reach out and grab anything
of course the satanic forces that
want human beings to be away from god
misguided you know they
are very busy in times of depression
times of uh
sadness and
and these kinds of circumstances where
it makes a person vulnerable
so these traps and tricks and
snares they've been there from the time
of
them there until
the end of this world but when people
are able to connect
with the correct knowledge which was
brought by the prophets of allah
may allah's peace and blessings be on
all of them i mean
then that provides them with a shield
against these forces but you know
it doesn't mean that uh the fact that
you've accepted islam
all of a sudden none of these things
affect you anymore
you know because for example of the live
in massroot
on one occasion came home and found his
wife
wearing a knotted cord necklace
something he hadn't seen her wear before
you know so
he had a suspicion that perhaps this
some other issues of coming in are
coming in here something
bordering on shirk or something of that
nature so he asked her what is this
you know why are you wearing it so she
said that you know her eye was twitching
continuously and wouldn't stop no matter
what she tried to do
so she went to this uh fortune teller
um soothsayer type
in the in the city in medina and
asked him for uh any medicine or
whatever he had to deal with this
so he gave her this cord necklace and
when she put it on it stopped
the twisting stopped in her eye so you
know
she was so happy she came home wearing
it
and so of the live masterwood he he
pulled it off her neck immediately tore
it off her neck and he said has the
the family of of of ibn masood
uh sunk to this level you know
so uh you know this is somebody who
obviously his wife is a believer you
know
this has happened to her in that state
of desperation
that drowning man will clutch at the
straw you and also whatever they can get
that uh can alleviate the situation when
there seems to be nothing then people
will reach out and grab for it
and so everybody is susceptible
to some degree the more one has
knowledge
obviously the the more one is
able to protect himself or herself
from such situations
so this type of offerings
as i said are not new and they will
continue to be offered
all the way until the last day you'll
hear
uh the stories of the jal and the tricks
that
he does on people it it comes to the
same thing
when people are starving to death he
brings mountains of
of bread and mountains of meat with him
you know and and and offers the people
here i'll feed you
you know you you just have to believe in
me you know when people are
you're starving to death what do you do
then
you know it takes a mighty you know
stroke of faith
to be able to say i'd rather die and eat
your bread
and your meat you know the meat you're
offering
so you know this type of trickery and
skullduggery
you know it's nothing new and it exists
in our times and it will exist
until the last day what i was surprised
to see when the muslim was
interviewing this famous youtube star
was that he actually had
something resembling uh
a third eye and he called it that he
said this is the evil eye
this is uh we also have a
evil eye that's hanging on my lamp
this kind of just helps fight off
negative energy uh
you saw that part yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and we have it too you know we
have uh
muslims they have the um the the
in north africa especially you know they
have the hand of fatima
it has like two thumbs on it you know
this is a protector
from evil eye and this kind of thing you
know or or they have this other
blue uh stone
you know which is polished and shiny and
they said you know this protects against
the evil eye
and you know there's no end of these
things this is nothing
new you know this is just caught
those people they have nothing else
left as he said in that dark point in
his life
where there was nothing else he never
got the message of islam
messenger of islam never reached him you
know
to give him that clarity and that
understanding
okay that you know in the end when we
look at all of these
uh options that people
are reaching out for and
thinking that okay this is another
religion this is another
group another spiritual movement or
whatever that has something else to
offer but
the reality is that the true offering
is only the offering of islam
everything else is
what we call mislam it's misguidance
it is everything but what god wants
for us okay so the person watches this
and he or she says
look i believe in god i'm a good person
this is just something now that i do i
see it works for me
what's it to you that's between me and
god
well the bottom line is that
we have revelation that has been
revealed
and if we want to get closer to god
it should be through revelation
not through stones and sticks and trees
and
you know planets and all this other
stuff
you know we we get closer to god through
the message that he
sent and the prophets that
demonstrated how to utilize this method
these messages no this is this is the
source of guidance this is for spiritual
guidance
you know it's not something that uh that
that comes from experimentation you know
you go
rock hunting and you know you gather up
a bunch of different rocks and
try this rock out for this you put that
one under your pillow
you know you put that one over your
doorway and cook with one
or whatever you know whatever works you
say okay
this is what i'm going with no this is
this is not
how we find spiritual guidance
and then in another part of the video he
talks about
i'm catholic but i don't really stick to
any particular religion i just take
bits and pieces a little bit more than a
year ago i became very spiritual
okay i was in a very dark place in my
life i noticed that you know becoming
spiritual and meditating
helped me a lot i wouldn't say i follow
any specific religion
growing up i was catholic but i i don't
really ever follow like a specific
religion i kind of grab it to pieces
from every religion kind of
use them to help me in my life that's
awesome
from this one and that one how would you
respond to that
well you know this is not new you know
people taking bits and pieces from
different places mixing them all
together and
coming up with something uh they give it
a new name or whatever
this is not new but this is not how god
guides he doesn't guide through
confusion the truth is clear
crystal clear as the prophet may god's
peace and blessings be upon him had said
that he left us on a clear white plane
whose night is like its day
and anyone who deviates from that is
destroyed
so pretty much it's not like uh burger
king have it your way it's not a buffet
it has to be god's way
it's his will be done not our will our
desires pretty much
exactly yeah in the next video clip we
see
you rub his stomach for good luck
and good things happen man good things
can happen
you know you know people
whenever they play with these matters
you know uh they're g they get trapped
when good things happen
because they assume
that there's a connection between the
rubbing of the buddha's belly
and the good things happening wow wow
tell us about this
that's big buddha you rub his stomach
for good luck
and good things happen man i'm not
buddhist
but it's nice but
that's not really the case you know good
things are happening around the world
without people doing anything the
ultimate
understanding should be that good
and evil are under the control of allah
that if we want good to come to us
then we should turn to god he is the
ultimate source of good
and it is by his permission that
certain evils happen in this world
so if we want protection from these
evils we should turn to him
because he is the only one ultimately
who can prevent
evil let me just run through a list
of common day practices and then if you
can tell us
what does this constitute from this
islamic perspective
we have these terms also if you could
define them tohid shirk
this is like the the bedrock of islam
and this is what really gravitates
people towards islam is when they really
understand the pure monotheism and then
what violates it
okay let's talk about knocking of the
wood when some people talk
and then they'll say hey we'll meet up
uh friday or
we'll do this and then i'll say and then
i'll knock on wood and you give a great
example of a scandinavian uh
tree god at one point can you yeah this
is the origin
yeah the origin you know comes from the
scandinavian belief in
tree gods that whenever they would want
to speak to the god
of the tree they would knock on the
trunk
of the of the tree and then they would
address the god
so this we have inherited uh
from those uh pagan
days and uh beliefs of scandinavians
and also the same thing with the with
the uh christmas tree
you know it has its connections with
them also
bringing it into the house you know
before you had to go into the um
you went into the snow covered forest
and you went knocking on the tree now
you could just cut the tree bring it
back home and
you can do your knocking at home uh
black cat crossing the road you see
sometimes the black cat will come up and
people put their feet up when they're
driving
or they'll do something to the lines
that maybe go around the other block
they'll back up
yeah we call it superstition you know
but um
uh this is nothing new again you know
this is uh taking bad omens
you know people do it in all kinds of
ways and
societies they you know they they
they find no end of such you know
phenomena
to to take bad omens or good omens from
you know um the so the black cat
because the black cats were associated
with the witches
you know and the warlocks because they
were you know dressed up in black etc
and the images of them would be with
this black cat along with them
like the black dogs the hound of towns
of baskervilles and
you know these were evil entities you
know hounds
from hell you know so
black and and red these are colors
associated with evil
you also have the reading of cups
have you seen that this is also
something that's popular in
different places like some places in
bosnia turkey where they'll have a cup
they'll drink some coffee flip it upside
down
and then they'll turn it back and
they'll start reading into your future
well
this is another form of fortune telling
whether you do it with
you know the the leftover grains from
the coffee
or you use tea leaves you know the tea
leaves that are left in the bottom of
the
the cup after you drank your tea or
there are no end of such uh
practices fortune telling of course is
it's a form of shirk it is you know
when we when we believe that
this individual has the ability to
to tell you what is going to happen in
the future
and this ability only belongs to god
you know and he reveals what he wishes
of it through his prophets but other
than that
you know we have nothing that will tell
us the future
the future is part of the rape the
unseen the unknown
you know only to to god alone so
in doing that we are ascribing to his
creation
you know for you know in incidents
in his creation the ability to
to determine what is going to happen in
the future
now from those modern day examples that
we just saw with some of these youtube
stars
celebrities and then just some of these
examples that i'm giving
to you and the audience i mean we can go
on and on you have people you know when
you go out to
the night when someone goes out they
have their lucky shirt maybe throwing
some salt over their
back i mean when a person now what's the
the
what's the solution to this you know the
the
when a person gets to know the tohi the
pure monotheism
and does this this is one of the things
that really attracts people to islam you
know that islam gets rid of all these
strange incantations these superstitions
so now we don't have to go
through all all of how could people
recognize
how so they don't fall into this trap
like for another example it's like
someone will say like
you know when they want to emphasize
something emphatically they say on my
mama
right so understanding how could someone
really understand
what god loves is pure monotheism and
avoid what's called
the [ __ ] that that goes and nullifies
this monotheism and why is this so
important
well of course success in this life is
going to be determined by
the degree to which one connects with
god
you know and that connection
is through revelation
and that revelation was brought by the
true
prophets of god so the only way
for us to understand what this life is
about
what is our purpose here where are we
headed
what is in the life to come the judgment
and all of the other elements of the
unseen world around us
we can only understand it through the
prophets of god
and the revelation which they brought
so we have to step away from
what we know to be superstition you know
most people who follow this knocking out
wood and
keeping their fingers crossed you know
and all these other things
they know that this is just superstition
but yet they do it anyway you know just
in case
you know or i heard it did work for
somebody you know
maybe it would work for me you know this
is not the way
that we should be living our lives uh we
should be
living our lives in accordance with
revelation and true guidance so if
someone had a sheikh that's dear to them
or they read about a sheikh
or they had their homie or they had a
an ancestor and somebody now and they
just they they want to they're lonely
they want to connect with someone but
the person is dead
and they say look that brings some
solace to my heart you know i'm talking
to this person and i'm communicating
with them
it just brings some joy i'm sad i'm
depressed and you know is this
acceptable
well you know people say the same thing
about drugs
you know you just smoke up some
whatever and shoot some whatever and you
know i was depressed and you know now
i'm feeling happy
you know we don't we don't judge you
know right and wrong
good and evil you know based on how
happy it makes you feel
you know this is not the criterion for
determining that
because these things may be evil and
harmful
and um if revelation
guides us if we understand the
revelation properly
it guides us it will guide us to avoid
these matters and these things
you know yeah the person who has died
they're not gonna talk to you again
they're not going to come in your dream
and speak to you
if they do know that it is really
satanic
so for somebody going they come from a
christian background they
you know they say forgive me father you
know they go in the confession box they
say forgive me father for i have sinned
right this have you heard you've
obviously
heard this okay sure okay
confessional does this violate the pure
monotheism
of course that's of course because that
father
you know may be more sinful than you are
you know
and we have known that from revelations
that have come out
you know in the in the catholic church
in recent years
you know the pedophilia and all the
stats are going on but
how many people did those fathers who
were caught
you know in pedophilia uh forgive
what was the value of that forgiveness
you know so
the bottom line is that forgiveness is
only with god
i mean we can if we did something
harmful to another human being
to ask them to forgive you there's no
harm in that
you know because they can forgive you or
not forgive you
but ultimately in terms of forgiveness
for whatever you've done which is wrong
it is the forgiveness of god ultimately
which is going to make the difference in
your life
the forgiveness of that person may
make you feel better for that
instance that you did it or whatever but
ultimately
and you i'm not saying you shouldn't
seek forgiveness you should seek their
forgiveness
but ultimately it is the forgiveness of
god which matters
because maybe what you did was something
good
and that person suffered because of that
good
and you ask them forgiveness and they
forgive you but did that
forgiveness i really have any meaning in
in the bigger speak scheme of things no
it's the forgiveness of god which has
meaning are there categories to shook
and i'm going to just give you some
examples for people to
go ahead and connect more like for
instance and you can
do we categorize these or just shirk is
shook
for instance in chapter 2 102 in the
quran
god almighty allah is talking about
those who do black magic
okay a form of [ __ ] uh people who wear
the talisman
right uh we hear from the prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
it's a form of shirk swearing by other
than god almighty allah
a former shook you have the example of
the companions with the tree
a form of shirk the people who are
worshiping their rabbis
god almighty emphatically talks about
this okay coming being a former shirk
the story of people worshipping mary
example of shirk going to a fortune
teller right
if a person nullifying their prayer but
is it correct if they believe in this
it's a form of shirk
so are these all the same are these all
forms of shirt and are they classified
the same are there different levels
and does a person necessarily yeah go
ahead
what you what you're dealing with are
acts of
shirk now in terms of
how allah deals with the one who
does these acts that is
with him whether he forgives or not
that a person may do an act of shirk in
ignorance
and allah may forgive him you know
do we have examples that were given by
the prophet
in this regard so
in the end it is up to allah
who is forgiven and who is not but for
us
in this life wherever
worship in any of its forms
is given to other than allah
then we're dealing with shirk it may
come in many many different forms
you know and we do have minor shirk
where it where the a person
you know doing acts of worship for
the appreciation or admiration
or praise of human beings right
then the prophet sallam called this
now obviously that indicates that that
level of shirk is not equivalent
to the level of which nullifies faith
no that is a personal weakness you know
everybody
likes to be praised and it caught
somebody
in their worship you know it nullifies
the
the value and the reward of the worship
but it doesn't nullify that person's
faith
unless his whole life or her whole life
becomes that simply doing acts of
worship
you know for the praise of people
so when you say in in the bosnian
culture you'll see a lot not to pick on
any
culture in particular other cultures
have also things that are just kind of
crept in but you'll hear you'll see
people saying mata me like when they
swear on something so just i know we
covered this but
this how can you replace it if you want
to swear by some that's kind of
translated like
on my mother right it's a strong
emphatic
ness on okay i swear to you on my mother
or my dead
father like so what should you replace
is this acceptable or you should replace
it with something else if you want to
really give your word to something well
you know the the prophet sallam has told
us that
you know if we are to swear by anything
we should swear by allah so
that's who we as muslims should be
swearing by we should not be swearing by
his creation
you know whether by you know the prophet
you have some
societies where they love to say you
know you know
in by the prophet you know
one nabi or something like of that
nature
or uh other
human beings other saints etc swearing
by them or by their graves etc etc
and even by the kaaba you know you had
people would do this but it should be
by the lord of the kaaba not by the
kaaba
you know so all the time the the basic
principle
is that uh when we swear take anything
you know for our oaths it should be
allah
subhanahu wa let me end with this final
question when i
when i was also in bosnia and we we
talked about this there was
the people there they took me they have
a monumental site they have a site where
they have
a group of brothers that they actually
died
and now their caskets their tomb is
there
and then what people do is they go by
there and they'll put
like money and then you'll see people
lined up next to their like making dua
now they don't necessarily believe that
there and if you talk to the people they
don't believe their god
they have the divine divinity but
they're making dua
through them to allah because they felt
that they
the way they died was a blessing so
does this constitute is this a form of
the nullification of tahit
and shirk that
well you know the point is that of
course
we can hear a
quantitative difference and qualitative
difference
between calling on the dead
directly you know for example like
the shia will call on ali
or they'll call on fatima and they will
call on them and ask them to do things
directly
and we have muslims all over the world
calling on
saints in india in egypt you know
wherever you go in the muslim world
indonesia they have them and people go
there
and call on them to do things for them
now that
is out and out
now the other thing where they are not
calling on them to do something directly
for them
but they're calling on them to pray to
allah
for them to we're still asking them to
do something
it may be not as direct
but it is indirectly you're still asking
them
to pray for you on your behalf and now
if you ask a statue or a stone
to do the same how are we going to look
at that
you know the believers that's obvious to
them if you go to idol of buddha
and you call on buddha and say okay
buddha please you know talk to allah and
have him do this for me you know people
are going to say hey
that's shirk what you're doing is shirk
but what is the difference between
statue
of buddha and the dead human being
in reality neither of them can do
anything for you
whether it is directly giving you
something
or passing on to to a higher power
what you need neither of them can do
that
so it should totally so justice i'm
sorry go ahead
yeah so i said just as in the same way
it's very obvious
to any muslim that if you say okay is it
okay to pray to buddha and ask him to
speak to allah for you no muslim in his
right mind
or her right mind would say to you yeah
that's okay
you're not asking buddha to do something
directly for you
but now when you when you're saying okay
but this is a human being
so what the human being is who is dead
you know that corpse in the grave bones
dust
do they have any more of an ability to
do
anything for you than the statue of
buddha does
it's all the same to allah you in your
mind you might say well this was a
person
and that's a statue but in the end it's
all
allah's creation it's all from dust
you've given examples like this before
for people who see what they would say
as miracles and they'd hear
sounds or see blood coming out or a
person might have
a arm that they cannot move and then
what happens i remember one time being
in the cab
and i was driving and the cab driver me
were having a discussion he was a
christian
and then when you got down to the root
of why he turned towards christ and
christianity he said that there was some
kind of ailment in his body
and then he called out in the name of
jesus somehow and then that went away
you gave some brilliant beautiful
examples how the jinn can actually they
can go ahead
and enter certain objects even your body
and then when you commit the act of [ __ ]
they can leave and now you attribute
that
to the creation to jesus to somebody
else a saint and then you get trapped
you get tricked and you found the trap
of [ __ ]
can you elaborate on that you even gave
an example about about how in the quran
how now the the golden calf and then
it was it made the sound
yeah well you know i think you've
already clarified
um what the points are but uh reality is
that
uh it is nothing new in in
in human history but these were all your
these these were these were all examples
that you gave i'm just repeating the
examples do you do you remember these
yeah well you
yeah i remember them of course you know
but you explained them already
it's like double kill overkill okay you
know i think the points are clear yeah
but you know just the last point that
you mentioned you know just to
at least touch on it that um
that when you look at the the concept
of the followers of prophet moses
you know um when moses went
up to receive the revelation
the torah and he left the people behind
and that individual referred to in the
quran as asamiri
told the people to gather their
jewelry melted it down
and whilst it was melting in in the pot
he took some dust and he threw in it and
he told them
this is some dust from the footprints
of an angel so let's put some magic
in there some serious power in that
mix and then out of it they poured and
made this
golden calf and the people looked at the
golden calf
reality is that nobody fell down in
in prostration to the golden craft
they've seen idols before
they came out of egypt they'd seen all
the egyptian
gods and you know they've said
no end of it so they were just looking
at it
wondering okay so what's the point here
then the calf
mood load it said moo
and that was enough for them to fall
down
in sujood before it because
this is something as
it would appear to them to be
supernatural that this
calf now had something which none of the
other idols had it was capable of
you know uh communicating
at least as a sound or whatever so that
was enough to
win them over and just like the case
which happened
in the case in the case of
the um the idol ganesh
you know um where all around the world
on on on the same day you know the idol
uh milk uh
started to they were pouring milk over
it
as part of their uh the hindu worship
pouring milk over the statue
and the milk started to go into the
mouth
of course ganesh is the elephant head
god
you know he's got a human body and he's
got a head of an elephant
and there's a story behind it about how
he had a head before and he said got
chopped off and you know
they put a elephant's head and that he
became the elephant he had god
anyway the point is though that you know
in the uk
all over india different parts in the
world where people were worshiping
the god ganesh the elephant had god and
we're pouring
milk over it over the head the top of
the head
down over the idol and the milk started
to go in
to what the area would look like the
mouth
of the eye bill and it happened all over
you know and we have to say how was that
well of course when you understand the
world of the jinn
it's not a problem you know it can be
easily explained
when you don't have any idea of the
world of the gin then it looks like
a miracle you know and this
what what was we have to look at what's
the end product of that
the end product is that it affirmed for
the people
their shirk their belief in the elephant
god
now became immutable you couldn't touch
it
if you came to them and said no this is
just i listen no
i've seen it i've seen the elephant head
god
ganesh drink milk you explain to me how
that took place
you know so the point is it's the same
thing with the exorcisms of the
catholics you know we you know you had
all these movies made about you know
uh people were possessed and they would
hold up the cross
you know when the cross is held up or
when the holy water was sprinkled on
them you know the people were jumping
and all this
if you don't understand the word of the
jinn then of course
you conclude that the evil spirit inside
is being driven out
by the power of of christ
you know but in fact it was
only the affirmation of shirk
in the presence of the jinn who were
controlling those people the word
i had entered into those people at work
were affecting those people
once the shirt was affirmed
this idolatry was affirmed in the minds
of the people through these
acts then the jinn left
they were not driven out by the power of
the christ
through the cross or whatever they left
willingly
because their job was done so
this repeats itself time and time again
with the idols of those who worshiped
idols directly
or in dreams or you know
in visions you know people have visions
in different parts of the world
where they've seen you know mary with
the christ child and you know then that
place becomes a holy place a place of
pilgrimage people coming from all over
the world
this just keeps repeating you know
shaytaan
satan is just playing with these
people's
faith and their souls and
trapping them in
idolatry which is the
negation of true belief
in god we're coming to an end a couple
more points
did jesus moses abraham
all the messengers that god almighty
sent
to guide humanity and the last and final
messenger prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him did they indulge
in any of these practices or the
companions of jesus or the companions of
prophet muhammad those who
were guaranteed paradise that they
indulge in any of these acts
that we're talking about that constitute
the nullifiers of tahit invoking people
in the ground dead people this that and
the other
that we have examples of of course not
of course not that would be misguidance
those who were around jesus and around
muhammad sallam
and around moses etc they carried the
message
the true followers carried the message
which they brought which was to worship
allah alone you know so the religion
the bottom line is that the religion of
god
is one religion and this is an important
fact to remember
because people like to you know
generalize and and put it in such a way
that
like how do we know there are so many
religions out there you know
how do we know that yours is the right
one
well the bottom line is that there are
not so many religions
there are only two religions
one is the religion of god and the other
is the religion of satan it's as simple
as that
one is the religion of worshiping god
alone
following him submitting to him alone
and the other
is worshipping other than god
because if if in your religion you're
worshiping other than god
then you are ultimately worshiping satan
satan and those who are connected with
him etc
you know so there are only two and we
should keep that in mind especially when
explaining islam to others that you know
it is not a whole bunch of
of religions out there that you have to
go and check out you know to find
out where which is the right one no all
you need to do is to look to see
who are they worshiping what you're
going to find
is that only in islam they are
worshiping god
alone without any partners
without any uh
taking away of his attributes and giving
it
in one way or another to the creation
it's only in islam but you find out
all of the others whether it is judaism
christianity
buddhism shintoism etc all of the
various
forms of idolatry which are out there
all of them
have that common factor of idolatry
there
where other than god is worshipped
so christianity worships jesus
believing that he is god but is he god
of course not he wasn't god
he can never be god he is a creation of
god
and those who believe in buddha and
worship buddha
the same thing he is a creation of god
no matter how righteous he may have been
you know in fact or whatever
but that didn't elevate him beyond the
status of a creation of god
but we love jesus can we say that
emphatically that we love him
of course we should love all those who
are righteous
all those who are good are our
the sincerity of our faith also depends
on loving jesus and believing in him
as a prophet of god
to not believe in him as a prophet of
god
is going against the revelation of god
okay we know that and this is to
conclude now
how much knowledge because most of our
problems would go away
here if we have a sincere and genuine
attempt now
to humbly go ahead and like what you
said earlier to
understand the revelation the quran and
we have the example of the last final
master
the authentic hadith and we see in there
the first revelation that was sent
read recite proclaim i mean this is the
first revelations we see that the last
final messenger
prophet muhammad peace and blessed be
upon him he said that the one who takes
a path seeking knowledge god almighty
allah will make the way easy for him to
jannah
we have other examples how the angels
lower their wings of mercy to the seeker
of knowledge
let's talk about your in the last minute
that we have you've actually set up i
mean
not only have you dedicated your life to
clearing the many misconceptions about
islam
also educating people through your
university can you talk to us how people
can go ahead and get grounded
in the dean with proper knowledge
well the bottom line is
that knowledge is
the determining factor
distinguishing between right and wrong
good and evil
so if we want to be clear then it will
come
through knowledge not through
personalities
you know emotions emotions
should follow knowledge if emotion
precedes knowledge
then the emotion will block the mind
from
properly understanding realities in
front of them
so seeking knowledge has always been
revered by all of the prophets of god
and as you mentioned the
number of statements that the prophet
muhammad the last of the prophets may
god's peace and blessed be upon all of
them
you know he spoke about how important
knowledge is and so much so
in another narration he had said that
the whole world is cursed
and everything in it is cursed meaning
that if we are
addicted to it if we become addicted to
this world
and the things that make up this world
our lives will be cursed
we will not end this life happily
we will live a wretched life if we are
addicted to the dunya to this world
in the end the prophet saw went on to
make an exception he said except for
the remembrance of allah except for
the remembrance of allah that if we
remember god
we reflect on his messages to us
his guidance etc then that
is not cursed it can never be cursed
it will always be good it will always be
blessed
and the prophet went on to add to it
the teacher and the student
basically telling us that this is the
relationship that we should favor the
most in this life
to be either a teacher or a student
or both because
what does the teacher do he passes on or
she passes on
knowledge what does a student do he or
she
accepts gains knowledge
and then what makes that knowledge
valuable is to act on the knowledge and
to disseminate that knowledge and that's
why the prophet salallahu said
that the best of you are those who learn
the quran
who learn and understand the teachings
of the quran
and pass that on to others
not as some people mistakenly think
that hadith with the brothers
they have taken this to be
father the best of you are those who
memorize the quran
and have other people memorize it that's
not what the prophet saw
said what he said was the best of you
are those who
learn the quran
learn the quran and this is very very
important because
to a large degree in much of the muslim
world people have gone
to extremes for memorization i remember
reading a story a few years back
in the in canada and montreal a muslim
woman
beat her child to death because he
wasn't memorizing the quran fasting
the teacher was complaining that he
wasn't you know is forgetting all the
time
so she beat him and beat him until he
died
imagine that you know this is the
misunderstanding
or the lie that is circulated in in the
name of a hadith
that the one who memorizes the quran is
able to take
seven generations of his family
to paradise with him fake
fabricated hadith alive and so you find
the families
in in places like pakistan and others
believe in this hadees and it circulates
amongst them they will you know the
father will sit down with all the kids
and
say okay you you
your job is to memorize the quran
we will deal with business we'll work
and
do everything that needs to be done for
the family and everything we will take
care of you
you just memorize the crime because
you're the one that's going to take us
to jenna
this is this is nonsense this is total
nonsense it's a lie people who have
heard this
and believed it please know that this is
a lie
so we need to get back to the way of the
prophet
muhammad
he taught the quran he memorized the
quran
people around him around him memorized
the quran also
but the vast majority of his companions
never memorized the quran
many of them after he died they did
memorize
but still the vast majority if it was
understood
that the most important thing so
what is really required of us is to
focus
on the meaning of the quran what is the
message
in the quran itself this is what
will change change individuals
change communities change the world
it's that understanding of the
revelation
so this should again become the focus
for us as it was the focus for
the the early generation
and with that focus
we know what has happened in his
in terms of the spread of islam to all
corners
of the earth
so uh let us
keep on programming understanding and be
blessed
achieving the guidance that
the quran explained
this book in which their guidance
for those who fear allah it's
about
shay where can people sign up to the
university
the international open university
provides degrees
in islamic studies bachelors
masters and phds as well as in arabic
but it also provides knowledge in
education
degree bachelors in education
in psychology business and and
finance business administration
information technology etc but the key
which makes the international open
university unique
is that the subjects are all taught
from an islamic perspective that
knowledge that secular knowledge which
is
well known in different parts of the
world is
presented from an islamic viewpoint
you know because there is there's a
place for islam
and everything
so it is about knowing where islam fits
into our
degrees our specializations whether it's
engineering
it's medicine it's driving a cab or
whatever
there is a place for islam and we should
know
its place and ensure
that we are living in accordance with
the islamic guidance
in our lives okay jazakallah thank you
so much may god almighty allah
continue to bless you preserve you you
and your fam
your big family
bless you for your efforts i mean and uh
you know so many so many people have
hope and uh speak very highly of you
something they do for you
[Music]
subscribe right now